and I decided to pick a game today from
one of the older matches that I have not
studied too deeply myself a lot of the
older ones I'm catching up now more of a
modern Internet player so here we have I
decided to pick a game between fm
Bogle Juba Bogoliubov somebody can
correct me but he was a very strong
world championship contender who played
two matches against Alexander I liking
something I think that's close and this
was 1929 World Championship so without
further ado d4 I think this is for ya no
I don't remember which game it was in
the match it goes of 14th or something
d4 Knight f6 c4 b6 so this was 1929 guys
theory was not as well developed
although b6 is kind of coming back into
fashion now which is kind of interesting
how I mean guys like me having studied
chests the older matches so a lot of
people want to surprise surprise us by
playing older theory or older things so
b6 is actually a little bit in fashion
these type of moves not developing the
center and bling b6 type of hyper modern
stuff so it's interesting B 6 plate yeah
black you know we're just Bishop e7 and
there are some benefits but one of the
big downsides is potentially the pawns
can run you down in the center for white
of white really gets that Center going
really fast and it's gonna be very
annoying to play against the game start
as black especially like the the bishop
we're committing the bishop to a
diagonal that isn't for sure we're gonna
be really good I mean like and block it
with d5 or white can maybe play I have
3/4 it's not it's not one of those cases
where it's a strong diagonal no matter
what but that was the theory at the time
that he prepared so here
Knight c3
threatening me for the logical this
should be 7 and f3 so that's what I
that's what the first thing that comes
to my mind I don't know if this was
prepared or whatnot but it seems logical
to me that white plays F 3 and E 4
rather than a move like that F 3 because
that does give the bishop more scope on
that diagonal like a pawn is better to
block that Bishop than with the piece
you know so so I mean I probably just
playing off a principle and you know F 3
F 3 makes sense there prepare you for
next move and you get that big Center
going once again guys can ask any
questions here and any moments totally
interactive or kind of analyzing this
together so d5 d5 is trying to it's
pretty much the only move right anything
I was like II 64 and well we can see
visually how nice this is for white you
have space for his two bishops I don't
know just nobody wants to give up space
for free without any type of positional
compensation so so d5 d5 is the last
moment you can do d5 and it moved like
c5 right d5 and then it's like well why
did we develop our Bishop to d7 we
should have kept it on c8 because now
it's just kind of like blocks forever so
black has to try to justify developing
that bishop early to b7 so he's going d5
now you for is not possible so C takes
d5 Knight takes d5 right you know keep
that this should be for Knight xe3 B
takes c3 and I guess this is one of the
reasons why this game is a bit easier
for me to cover or something
this type of pawn structure comes from
the grünfeld defense very very popular
opening these days and one of my main
weapons and it comes from the top Tara
and
in d4 as well in some variations but
this type yeah this type of structure is
it's pretty common in a few different
openings so it's generally useful to to
you know be familiar with it because
sometimes it sometimes it happens
through different different move orders
in different openings yeah so this
structure can be good you know it's
dynamic white gets the big pond center
but yeah some weaknesses c3 can be a
weakness in the end and potentially
black can get a queen-sized majority
it's there's pluses and natives although
you know white is still still better II
didn't you know didn't do anything wrong
here g6 u6 now at least you have the
option of playing c5 without them
playing d5 all all standard so far there
should be 5 check this is this is a now
this move is also pretty normal I'll
explain it briefly Bishop b5 why why
Bishop b5 because they're just going to
place they could play c6 and and don't
they win a tempo it's not really a good
tempo and the point is why does not only
gonna develop his Bishop anyways like
Bishop d3 but by going Bishop b5 if it's
something like c6 and then he plays
Bishop d3 he's happy giving up that move
for black because black is now you know
maybe blocked his Bishop so it wasn't
really a good a useful useful useful
time gaining move for black so there
should be 5 and he responds 97 probably
for the reasons I explained xe6 c6 also
maybe even Bishop the ship here but it's
not a benefit for blacks to develop that
Bishop and put a pawn right in front of
it so 97 keeps things flexible they've
traded off a piece already so maybe the
knight can eventually go to have six or
something it does have it does have a
square to go to at some point 92 I mean
what black is still I mean white is
still maybe maybe waiting for C 6 C 6
and then he can maybe move the bishop
back so developed by now I know it has
to be developed no matter what there
should be seven castle
first he could have gone you could have
castles as well but Asics not bad and
the bishop has to decide who you know if
it's going back here if it's going here
right off the bat I'm a six is the
lesser of the evils like see six blocks
that Bishop so a six is not really
generally a weakening move Bishop d3 and
c5 so this brings up an interesting
point
you know black white and black Castle
why is black playing c5 before castling
is that just you know both were good and
just felt like that or you know is this
a situation where maybe should keep the
options flexible and you might Castle
queenside or you want to keep the option
to castling queenside as as black
because you know castling is looks looks
like maybe the most natural move other
other than c5 maybe looks pretty pretty
solid as well and then play c5 the
easiest way I can explain it's probably
black is like I mean what's the danger
of not castling is they take advantage
of your King in the center block his way
the option series like by delaying a one
move there is no big attack that can
kind of come up and stop me from
castling in this situation so c5 is a
move I want to play no matter what I
want to challenge that Center I can do
it now and maybe there's also an
opportunity in the future where I keep
my King in the center or our Castle
queenside but see father's move I have
to play Castle castling as a move I
probably want to play but not for sure
but I definitely want a challenge a
center and there's not a way for white
to to take advantage of that right now
with the way his pieces are like my king
is safe either way castles are in the
center so that's that's probably how he
came to that conclusion but yeah c5 is
pretty standard to try to try to try to
put some pressure there yeah
there should be to some other candidate
moves would probably be for you guys
something like there should be three
there should that for it was all looked
pretty reasonable so there should be to
Queen c7 again I think black is
realizing yeah I mean white is he likes
the center I as is right now he's not
really going to attack me yet he's gonna
put his pieces nicely and use that space
advantage so I don't I don't notice how
I have to Castle right away because my
king there's no threats against it Queen
c7 is useful moving again it keeps the
option open of castling queenside so
there could be a situation where he
decides to cut you know it just keeps
things flexible
and the other moves pretty is down it's
pretty pretty straightforward they both
have options so they decided to pick
what they did and we'll see how they how
they go with that Queen c7 f4
yeah maybe now I have to remove like f4
black f4 makes sense what was his
thought process I'm guessing now after
move like F why did he play a four it's
like okay four is logical and everything
like that but he's realizing black
hasn't committed a castling
so I actually probably should try to
force him or put some pressure on him
he's taking a lot of time what black is
taking a lot of time the castle and I'm
not doing anything about that I'm
letting him put his pieces and things
like that so why probably you know who
decides now take issue with that and and
have some threats there are some there
are some threats coming up pretty soon
well you know you can already at least
get a bit closer to the king and take
the space that's available
the downside is is that dark away
earlier is now this bishop has a bit
more scope that pot on you for is now
not going to be stable it does not upon
supporting it so it's going to be a
little bit loose for the two pretty much
the rest of the game unless you can
block that Bishop on b7 somehow but it's
going to be defended by pieces so that's
that's not the same as being defended by
a pawn ah defending defending this with
a pawn neutralized it's quite a bit
because this Bishop isn't tied down to
the protection of that so much but now
after a four you do have to defend you
forward with some pieces so that's not
as not as ideal in some cases so so a
force plate Knight f6 remember no guys
yeah you know black blocks not taking on
d4 why would take back with a pawn and
it justifies this move on b2 quite a bit
more that bishop is closer to getting a
very very nice diagonal so that's why
box not doing it so you know he's
keeping the tension there let's see what
else besides that then okay you know a
big no-no just just to clear
anything like this leaves you with two
pawn islands very bad pawn structure
unit that even if you open up this thing
that just just no it's just ugly to pawn
to permanent weaknesses you don't want
to compromise your pawn structure so f4
to me or one thing that seemed
interesting was maybe e5 here as well
that's consistent with a pawn structure
so you 5 seems seems like maybe a better
choice or an alternative though one of
the nice things about it is that this
Bishop is not as good because it's just
facing a pawn that's not weak so maybe
maybe that can be that can be considered
an improvement yeah
f4 United is Knight f6 again not not
castling and now becomes a bit more
apparent because white played out for
like why if you castle
could have done it could have done it
but if you did it now I'm pretty certain
it moved like ie 5 or something
somewhere might be played with with
ideas of playing at five next move and
and getting something going f5 right
away maybe not so much maybe you can tap
try to close things down with me five
but you don't have
yeah it's can't get that many pieces
over the black to offend the king sad so
he decided not to not to castle once
again but Knight f6 a good move as I
said before has now been weakened a
little bit Knight g3 well there's no
there's there's a few moves to to defend
from this from from like defend e4 you
have 93 keeping the pawn on e4 you have
a five advancing the pawn and now it's
not the red threatened or Queen c2 and
Queen B one
so 93 yeah your four moves formulas as
far as I can see then you pick 93
anybody if anybody likes or dislikes I
don't know
anybody I'm surprised like maybe some of
you guys might prefer you five that's a
bit more straightforward maybe I think I
might be might be interested in that
it's a bit double-edged you didn't go if
you five probably because of the
consequence of a longer night to get to
d5 where the threatens threatens this 93
but it could maybe it could have been
playable I'm not not entirely sure Queen
d2 or something it's risky it's risky
but he's already playing for diversity
setup yeah so 93 93 he leaves him with
the least amount of like positional
concessions he didn't give black any
super nice squares yet but I met on g3
is it's also actually pretty we'll see
what happens right here h5 night on g3
is not not the most stable Square and H
5 H 5 is played and shows blacks
intentions a little bit you know he's
keeping the King in the center or the
Queen side now and that's that's been
that's why I was beneficial that he made
useful moves before casting because
moves like this would not have been
possible he was Castle so probably he
actually just evaluated things correctly
like yet a bunch of useful moves to make
first there was not nothing I could do
to stop that and now white you know
white took took action played out for
but he leaves himself open to a
counter-attack from kind of like both
both sides so after an edge e3 h5 I like
doing this with myself quite a bit I
like to line casting myself quite a bit
although it comes with experience
h5 is probably probably why it's not too
happy here probably considering maybe
you should move this Queen there to be
one but after you know h5 and moves like
h4 usually not ideal it was like Neji 4
come to mind
threatening 93 and Bishop h4 but yeah I
mean
not only is it for going to be
threatening the night after the night
moves maybe h3 and you're just provoking
you're just chipping away at blacks and
whites defensive set up a little bit
there and being being annoying and being
annoying without giving any targets
though because I mean black set up his
Bishop is on b7 Bishop on e7 it's not
that easy to to attack there aren't any
clear weaknesses the only thing that's
almost clear is why it has to use that
Center space maybe just come directly
Adam like as soon as possible because on
the sides there's not much the target
box pieces are pretty there they're the
replace third place on the seventh rank
for the most part so queening it to play
9h five-year move like h3 to provoke
some weaknesses on the King is good and
bad one bad part about it is white could
literally consider playing with like g4
and maybe g5 I mean he's not gonna take
on h3 I'm not gonna take take for the
most part just that just messes off of
his pawn structure and opens up the line
for the rook it couldn't be going g3
it's maybe they safer version and g4 is
what I suggested I they're aggressive
the g3 and let's say we make a couple
moves well in this position is hard for
blacks to castle but white is gonna go
Knight f2 and it's very hard for black
to actually access this this type of
square so unless you can access that
that pot on h3 is the weakest spot in
the entire game and can drop it's gonna
could drop a game or something but it's
a weak pawn and unless that G 2 square
is accessible that's probably you know
objectively just better for white he
hasn't really made white hasn't really
made it any like bad moves like for the
most part so white should should not be
too worried about type of bum rush like
with Age 3 so net netted five now net f2
is not in the night except for is a
threat
well why is black taking so much time
and not casting like he can't counsel
right now because of Bishop Bishop a6
right pawn is upon like it's it's not
and you can't really stop that threat
with a move like b5 I'm just going to
wait for like now now there's definitely
a sense of urgency for black because
white has connected his rooks and you
know he's ahead in developments the
logic is you definitely start attacking
black especially because he's not
castled he does not his rooks in the
game you can sacrifice material but you
know that you have more pieces available
to attack so like white well it's surely
getting ready to the fully attack and he
probably can sacrifice a bit because why
doesn't a black doesn't have the maximum
from his pieces with his King in the
center so net age five at least carries
a threat so you know white why can't
attack quite yet queen g4 defending f4
and being a bit annoying I guess that's
the best way to put it
maybe g7 falls in some lines but I mean
what other ways would you you when you
look at the other options Queen g4 makes
more sense they should see one you don't
want to admit you know you want to move
your Bishop back right off the bat
g3 you don't want to let's say we trade
once I'm just gonna move back as black
and we gave this rook a file for free
without a challenge the king is a bit
less safe on g1 Queen f3 do we really
want to put the Queen in the line of the
bishop no Queen g4 seems kind of one of
the safer ones there's also a move of
Queen f2 or Queen d2 but Queen g4 keeps
keeps black black in line a little bit
you can't not you have to watch out with
your knight your night might hang on
some lines f5 is being supported quickly
here it makes sense it makes sense just
based on the other options we inside
Castle that's that's that's how blacks
office counseling problem
so it did work out in the end but you
know this this position is still pretty
unclear
it's not parent how how black is going
to attack continued to start to attack
now that is rooks are potentially in
where and white as well it would be nice
the white could do something in the
center use those pawns to restricts
black a bit more they're doing a good
job of restricting blacks Queenan and
and Knight a little bit but the bishops
can still operate pretty effectively
from the back so black black still has
head space even though he has a lot less
a lot less than white he still has
enough to have some pieces doing their
job so now rook 81 working you one
preparing to to push in the center there
are some other moves to consider
sometimes you know pollinate it to is
upon island after all sometimes you know
a4 can seriously be considered you what
you want to do is you that it literally
just want to push the pond down and if
you can trade it off fantastic and I'll
get it
get a weakness off the board open up the
file otherwise yeah this is it this is a
thread and you just want to provoke
weaknesses it's it's it's usually when
you Castle you know opposite sides it's
a sharper game and and you have you both
sides have good attacking chances so
pretty much I could decide to do that
and it's a fairly common I mean as black
if you were to reply with something like
85 then white is already happy he's done
his job he's made some permanent
weaknesses here that that weren't
available when he didn't push that pond
like you provoked a weakness then he
would maybe just take advantage of that
at some point so that's it that's the
move that consider ku1 playing in the
center over protecting a little bit you
could say I'm when I'm looking at this
from White's point of view we can even
flip the screen a little bit we've been
looking at blacks front of you let's
fill the screen
I'm actually I'm curious guys who
prefers I'll give a few seconds but I'm
curious which which color you guys
prefer in the position or kind of the
entire game the games been going like
it's kind of been steadily like this for
the most part black is taking potshots
at white structure white still has that
structure intact so there's
counter-attacking chances for black
whereas white has that like you know
that's solid foundation that that nice
that nice space advantage and keeping up
with kind of conventional wisdom who
prefers white got a couple who prefers
black who's not sure or like it kind of
like on the fence or you cool and clear
you know it's close to 5050
close to 5050 I see that sounds about
right
and there are gonna be different
preferences though like between players
like I played the Grunfeld which is
counter-attacking so I kind of like
black in these structures but at the
same time this is pretty impressive
Center for white yeah so he does work EU
won if anybody has some who's they see
now that we flip the board they see some
stuff they might like for why some
interesting attacking ideas I mean yeah
a4 right
yeah a 44 you know I think I think at
this time I'm saying this is 1929 guten
Fells was not in you know and it
fashioned a few other struck like this
type of structure was not as well known
and now people play for all the time all
the time against against this is opening
although it's still not fully clear if I
if you play it for and I let's say even
like just move my king over it was like
a5 b5 which is what black will do it
don't want to open the lines in front of
the king so with 81 and and rookie you
wanna yeah I'm not a big fan of it I
feel like there's no pressure on blacks
position I'd be pretty happy playing
black here there's no no pressure he's
the one who can kind of annoy white and
white has to always watch out for
tactics against the sponson okay
we're still not sure about this Bishop
on b2 right like it might might be there
for the rest of the game that Bishop was
on e3 maybe we would have that B file
and C file and we wouldn't have to have
a queen on g4 defending force oh yeah we
see we see some of the serious negatives
of that bit about b2 because we have a
queen queen and rook defending this pawn
on f4 and he doesn't want to play the g3
to open up this rook but it's not really
ideal that he has has to keep his pieces
there to defend from that part when he
could have solved it all with the bishop
so Rick au1 can be a natural move you
see this disposition no matter who
prefers who it's easier to play for
black for the most part hanging pawns
that's kind of just the theory I mean
with hanging pawns they get a weakened
endgame so the end games can get quite
dangerous and in the middle game yeah I
mean they're high-risk high-reward epic
thing they want once once one of them
Falls and kind of all collapses it's a
pretty aggressive structure so you know
the bigger they are the harder they fall
once once things go bad it goes really
bad so you do have to be very careful I
need any new single move of some sort of
collapse of that Center and white is
over protecting with moves like rook a
new one I have five f5 finally he's
actually pushed one of the pawns on to
the other side of the board said y d5
didn't work d5 okay d5 dozen workers
hanging he five if he wanted to be five
we know he could have done it like ten
years ago because that was available
then with maybe a better position so he
thought was it was playable but he's
gonna do it he probably probably should
have done it earlier that five is the
last move then question guys two moves
here immediately come in mind is taking
the pawn as black or playing e5
what's wrong with what what about he
takes that five is that good or bad I
mean okay why just running to take on
you six and the most natural moves would
be they're just moving that pond away
first and then so I'm just looking at
the the first immediate movie takes out
five what's the downside of this it's
something I discuss it's kind of the
structure that you kind of want to
achieve is white you're right so you
were saying rook have five Bishop c8 yep
so then the forcing take with a piece
that means taking with a queen so why
okay what's going on here or at least
what's what's kind of available here I
mean the one downside of this is black
or one of the downsides as I was saying
why do you want to get that protected
passed pawn not only is it a good asset
like a blocks at Bishop on on b7 so by
getting by losing this you you get that
like that that's one of them other thing
here there's probably a couple other
other reasons there are some tactics now
there are some tactics now so it's not
that clear but he didn't do it but I'm
trying to figure out why he didn't do it
I mean besides I know I mean there is a
threat of Queen f7 here it looks like
white spawns are very losers position is
very shaky like even lose like Bishop d6
Bishop d6 hitting h2 I mean now you 5 so
it probably doesn't work and you the
bishop has to move but it's lines are
being opened more and more and and
blacks King is looking safer than whites
so he's probably happy to go for
complications he didn't go for this
maybe we're missing something right
right right off the bat or the gist the
other option is more appealing g5
shutting down shutting down shutting
down this bishop diagonal I guess I
guess I guess there is a bit of logic
here we compared like if we look at this
after taking and we see what happened
the game ie5 was played but it's very
concrete so it's not you know it's not
gonna sit following what we're saying
about kind of like we are white gets
that protected passed pawn and the
bishop gets blocks and everything but he
had something directly in mind c4 c4
immediately otherwise why will reinforce
that and that's a super strong protects
the past pawn and he gets his Bishop out
so he plays c4 move the bishop away and
Bishop c5 actually I mean one thing we
can say it's probably both of them are
playable
he takes f5 was probably also playable
but this type of structure that happened
was defined and he seemed like a laking
probably kind of understood a little bit
like he or he didn't mind this close
position that probably means he either
thought that's protected I respond
specifically isn't so good here or
there's a tactical problem with White's
position and having the structure but
you played c4 automatically Bishop c2
and this this happens in the Greenfeld
still it's a common idea Bishop c5 check
and Knight f2 so that's that is a very
concrete move order this so far what's
happened almost every move has been
forced d5 was forced I mean you wouldn't
want to take okay the bishop is hanging
otherwise black is threatening to win
the pawn so a lot of it's pretty forced
c4 we should see the Bishop c5 Knight f2
g6 and that probably means he's thinking
you know why I'm gonna close the
position and then that closed position
the only side that's going to be open is
the Kings side I have this g6 move
and when you're attacking it's nice to
have the rest of the board closed then
you just have a free hand you have to
worry about a counter-attack things like
that so that's why he played e5 into
this he blocked everything out
maybe he'll play Bishop c8 next move but
his logic was like he thought might I
can attack on the Kings side if I want
to do that why not just close the center
I don't have to worry about anything
else that's practically the the decision
like in his head and Queen side is
clearly white his way way behind there
so now the game is only being contested
on the Kings side and that's where my
that's not only where White's King is so
he's he gets to attack without
sacrificing about anything he just
needed to the only thing he didn't need
to concede was this protected past pawn
over here a type of structure but he
might have an idea to play around that
so that that's why the closed position
playing me five instead of taking seems
to be beneficial for just attacking on
one side you do want to close up the
other side of the board then you can
just focus on the attack for most cases
f2x g6 and now a nice move guys yep
rook d g8 correct when I open up the
lines he is now an attacking mode
White's pieces are very passive let's
see how this goes look d g8 now if you
don't go G takes looking first of all
why not have takes three six I mean why
did he go after excuses
I don't know what the time situation
maybe he's in time pressure but as I
said like black might be playing Bishop
C anyways and taking on that five and he
opens up the G file right guys so so
Bishop to c8 this right here and you'll
be putting pressure there so if he
doesn't do it now like it'd be ideal if
you were a white to defend to close it
up but that's just hanging right now it
doesn't quite work but like no matter
what like seems like there's gonna be a
serious amount of pressure with this
type of sequence anyway so he's doing it
now but it's just inevitable he can't
really stop that
so f takes g6
rook d g8 Bishop to c1 so I mean I think
we can conclude now that probably should
be to in the very opening was some
like didn't turn out to be a good
experiment there should be three would
have saved so much trouble in many
different situations
Bishop C one he is rerouting it that's
what you're supposed to do with a piece
without a future like that that's
completely blocked so that's that is a
good move but when your king is getting
attacked it might be too little too late
here this is just such a monster now
they should see a first you could also
take on g6 both ours you know this
benefits a bishop see it he needs you
wants to get all his pieces and Bishop
see it and he's not you know the pawn is
hanging on g6 no matter what so he's
like I'll develop my piece with tempo
first I'm going to take I can dig with
g6 with tempo as well and kind of also
play bishop see it but they both have
have some attraction to them and almost
get to the same position Queen f3 rook
g6 now Queen h4 you're really really
asking for it and probably move like
knight Knight f4 hitting the Queen and
just every single piece is almost
hitting hitting why there's it's not
looking very very good here so Queen f3
rook takes g6
so there's only one file now but that's
a G file but I mean it's not it doesn't
matter like the pressure there's no
pressure on black he's not getting
attacked on the Queen side osmium
sacrificed the pawn and as I said the
center is closed Queen side is slow so
he does have a free hand of attack he
doesn't need to go to sacrifice right
away he has a you can attack without
taking a big risk he's actually he's
attacking because that's what position
was asking for or not
no it's nothing reckless or risky here
it's the open part of the board opposite
side castling dynamic position pawn
structures different this is this is
just what he's supposed to do and his
pieces are in there king h1 well the
threat was among other things you can
double the rooks you can play 93 that's
an idea
there's there's a few different threats
I guess Bishop let's say Bishop III this
Bishop III is not so good because takes
let's say we take care and move like a
knight at 4 and g2 is really really
about to fall you'd have to play g3 and
hope you don't get checkmate it but g3
doesn't even threaten anything the
Knights not being threatening I mean if
I if I played a move like Queen c5 I
don't think there's a single move almost
for white here and there's no material
White House black is in sacrifice any
material so this is a really bad
position if anybody has some resources
for for white here I'm happy to hear I'm
looking at Bishop III I don't know like
but but we kind of see now this played
out a little bit and just seemed like
black understood the game and this type
of structure quite a bit more even when
he gave up kind of this this this
protected past opponent's White's not
gonna survive to any endgame or anything
like that
and why did if yeah White's so far done
a few questionable things he could have
gone his knight in the center his
Knights been on f2 which he thought was
nice hole in the center but it turns out
to be a bit of a burden right now his
bishop on b2 the experiment did not go
well his Queen to g4 experiment did not
go well so like there's been a few
little small mistakes here in there but
black is now kinda like punished it
pretty ruthlessly but like a few
different small things about the
structure not necessarily positional -
but anyways like it he definitely
definitely got his an opposite side
casting it's usually whoever attacks
first like you know it's doing good like
it's it there's usually less fundamental
like that's positional principles when
you're officer when it's also opposite
side casting there's a lot more tactics
and just direct attacking because when
your opposite side castles like you
there's an imbalance you do have more
pieces than the other guy when you're
attacking and vice versa so
you can you can get away with like just
attacking and doing stuff like this more
it's just the nature of it
so here but here here he's just done
everything right so King each one and
now what move Nigeria yeah yeah you've
been waiting you been waiting for that
and now now it's even it's like it's a
clean night g3 night g3 so he takes if
King do you want you just win the
exchange and you're strolling like just
just a show King g1 sometimes in the
exchange isn't winning but just a just a
show I double the rooks and you're gonna
take on g2 no matter what this night is
still pinned your your bishop on c2 is
absolutely brutal like a Bishop g4 just
wins the Queen here Oh fantastic move
this is Bishop g4 just when the Queen
well but the Queen can't move so he
takes so check takes actually you got me
thinking a bit here about Bishop g4
right now I'm just looking right now
because we're just suggesting Bishop g4
I'm just looking now this would be for
looks okay kind of nice that's you Adam
that's you Bishop g4 it looks pretty
nice I guess maybe Queen takes know it
might lead to mate but yeah maybe it
leads to me like it might still be what
it's it's pretty nice so how he did h6
g3 night h3 forced Bishop takes pawn
takes rook takes
King here I inject me yeah
so that's that's the conclusion the game
it was a pretty like you know dynamic
strategical game I mean like it kind of
well I as I said there's a few different
things that white it incorrectly and
placing his pieces seemed like he played
a little bit passive but it was a very
very very strong effort from black like
he's just completely outplayed on every
party and did all everything right I
don't really see any any mistakes but
now I enjoyed this game this structure
now with modern theory white does not
play like this as much they react a bit
more strongly like they don't just wait
for for black to kind of come up with
stuff so as I said like maybe you know
why why probably should have been a bit
more aggressive and with that Center
because in the end he just never got to
use any of that and he spent so much
time preparing that so just it was just
the typical dynamic clash space pawns
against counter-attack and activity so
hopefully a few things there but that's
that's that's the game from the 1929
World Championship match with the world
champion lay him playing as black he won
the match and you won the game